this is how they
they'd say it i don't you know they
don't go into depth or nothing they're
just like yeah i'm the teachers
like all the teachers they got guns yeah
so so to your earlier question is like
what's a solution that won't work
the problem with that is
the the problem with that is the details
of any solution you take any one of
these solutions and there's certain
details that would make it better and
some details if you don't include them
are going to make it a disaster like you
just throw weapons into every classroom
with random people that haven't been
trained you you that's that's going to
be a problem yeah right because you've
got teachers that are that are that
might go crazy right there's all kinds
of things going on
so
you take any of these solutions
and you take it to a certain extent i
mean some of the
some of the ways of looking at things
can be so different depending on who you
are
that
like what's the term they use reasonable
gun control reasonable gun control means
completely different things to different
people depending on who you are and what
your background is so true and so to
just say hey we should have reasonable
gun control like i said that means
completely different things depending on
who you're talking to yeah so
that's why for this for this i just want
to talk about hey here's something i do
know about and here's a pragmatic
solution that will help
and it should be
it should it should be implemented
brad that's so true huh because
there are there's guys and this is going
to come as no surprise but when you put
it into perspective where there are
people who
at six years old they got their first
gun six yeah yeah then
same country
same state a lot of time maybe even the
same neighborhood
they're people who've never shot a gun
ever in their life and they're like 60
years old yeah
so you figure someone who's never shot a
gun never handled the gun or whatever
the idea of a gun potentially can be
like that is just a death tool that is
just an
object of death so they just don't know
you know and then versus the guy who got
their gun at six and guns are all around
the house and cases and the truck and
you know all this stuff
where it's like no it's not a thing a
death is just a tool just like a saw or
a hammer or something like that where
you know how you know obviously people
say this all the time where it's like
hey you know if someone kills someone
with a hammer you don't outlaw hammers
it's like they literally feel guns are
the same exact in the same exact
category you see i'm saying but then the
guy the person who's never shot a gun
how he's gonna feel is like no a hammer
is to hit nails if someone gets all
crazy and starts hitting heads with it
that's different guns are made to shoot
people kind of a thing that's their
their attitude you know or their how
they feel about it so it's like yeah
then okay now okay now we need laws now
right for the guns but these laws apply
to everybody like six-year-old guy who
got his gun at six
and also the guy who's never shot a gun
ever in his life these laws have to
apply to both people so it's hard to
land those laws you know effectively
where everyone's going to like them yeah
it's very hard and
what makes it even harder is that the
two sides don't talk to each other
in a reasonable way to try and figure
out what would be a reasonable solution
yeah man and so there i am using the
reasonable gun laws myself using that
ambiguous term yeah it's true well and
then yeah because you kind of
it makes sense on a certain level even
though it's still
not effective right where let's say i
got a gun my first gun at six you know
rifles freaking awesome
i grow up all kinds of guns right i have
all kinds of guns i've shot my kids
shoot guns all this stuff and then you
have someone a whole family of people
who live next door or whatever across
the street
and they've never shot a gun ever in
their life and they're scared of them so
now they're like hey you know they're
we'll just say highly intimidated or
something like that so
they come about and they're like oh my
gosh like a gun or whatever and then the
the person who's used to guns are like
how you're kind of being dumb you're
kind of being unreasonable right now
like this gun you have to pull the
trigger shoot you know point out
something pull the trigger for it to
shoot whatever it doesn't just
automatically kill people right
so you're dumb for being scared about
that kind of stuff
it's reasonable that that would that
feeling would would kind of take place
you see i'm saying and then you have the
opposite feeling where it's like oh you
guys are gun nuts like you have like you
have 50 guns 50.
i've never shot a gun in my life i'm
scared of guns and you have 50 of them
is it unreasonable for me to be
uncomfortable if i'm like that
seems pretty normal is what i'm saying
so i'm saying like that conflict makes
sense to me